we're gonna do a fast around a speed
round describe this look in one word
modern French bad meaning good what's
the craziest or most painful thing that
you did to fit into the tape tape tape
double sided tape so I don't have a
wardrobe malfunction was this bot or
barbar oh yeah okay what's the first
chakras right yes indeed what's the
first thing you're gonna eat when you
take this on cupcakes
today's the twins birthday so yeah we
got birthday cup of tea I love that so
much
okay so I want to get to you two now
because your Black Panthers nominated
tonight hallelujah what kind of forever
what would it mean to you for your peers
just you know to look at you guys and
say well done oh it would mean that
everything's right in the world that is
right it's glorious hallelujah mall
manager and you know and and you can
change things up you know you know a
movie of this of this style you know
it's never you don't have a hard time I
mean it's accepted by their by the
audience is of course it's a global
sensation all of that but the awards
they tend to get push them to the side
but it was such a well crafted and well
made beautiful story I mean big moments
big big themes and I think is so utterly
worthless the stunt crew already won
tonight so there you go you got one
wrong girl but it does you know I always
actors always tell me this one we'd love
all the awards but this one always sits
a little deeper with them because it is
your peers Oh
with actors you know you you can you can
see you can see a moment when you but
you when you can see past the the
technique in the craft and you're just
right you know effect it right in the
gut in the heart and your spirit and
then you got to give it up is that's
what you're looking for is everybody
back for the sequel we didn't
technically see him go into the ocean
[Music]
how about Courtney be coming in I just
like the way it changed society it
really changed it was all about what
kind of ever and those kind of films
when they come around you got to lift
him up so that's what tonight is about
for me that movie changed society so
give it what it's do I would love to be
at the Black Panther table tonight
because I know y'all gonna party
[Applause]